alors nous sommes dans les locaux du
démocrate de laine à Vervins ce journal
a été créé en 1906 par Pascal Ceccaldi
c'est le dernier journal imprimé en
France et sûrement en Europe imprimé au
plomb à l'ancienne
et la première fois que je suis rentré
ce qui me frappé c'est l'écrin c'est le
lieu où on se trouve je dirais c'est une
ambiance un peu à Harry Potter on a des
toiles d'araignées sur les murs on a les
peintures qui sont encore 1906 on a les
vieilles affiches qui ont été imprimées
dans les années 70 ça a un côté magique
et puis après il y a les machines elles
sont sorties hors du temps on a
l'impression d'être dans l'univers de
Jean Genet avec des couleurs et des
formes complètement anachroniques qu'on
ne trouve pas aujourd'hui quand on voit
une imprimante informatique qu'on a sur
son bureau et la rotative qui fait 5m20
de long avec un bras comme une
locomotive à vapeur c'est vraiment
génial les enfants quand ils viennent
visiter le démocrate ils sont ils sont
émerveillés
la cinq salariés une journaliste une
secrétaire administrative de l'île aux
tipiste et nos deux techniciens qui
s'occupent de fabriquer le journal et de
l'imprimer au niveau de la ligne
éditoriale on a principalement quelques
informations en départementales ou
régionales des informations locales et
puis après des articles de fond des
articles historiques ont fait beaucoup
d'articles historiques
hop on leur fait
l'intérêt dans le journal c'est que on
va pas faire quelque chose de très
linéaire c'est à dire que les filets
sont pas toujours les mêmes par exemple
là on parle de la musique et ben on a
tout un fond de petits clichés qui
permettent d'avoir des motifs qui sont
qui sont forts sympathiques puis il y a
le côté ancre qui coule un peu sur le
papier c'est l'authenticité du journal
les puristes vont dire vous êtes pas
très bon parce que il y a des défauts il
y a de l'encre qui boivent il y a des
fils et qui ressortent des choses comme
ça mais c'est aussi un peu l'intérêt de
garder comme je dis la patine antiquaire
sur le journal Michel Moreau je suis
typographe et aux tipiste ici au
démocrate depuis 7 ans alors là c'est
pas une typographie pour moi non pour
les puristes typographe non nous tout ce
qui était typographie c'est tout ce qui
était le maître en plomb dans les casse
et caractère je vous fais avoir quelques
caractères
du journal nous vivons c'est de la
moscovite ici week-end d'étude Victor
Hugo 15 caractères du Centre Bourse et
de l'Américaine
c'est Victor Hugo
pour faire une page de journal à la ni
nautique il faut une journée donc c'est
un travail de fourmi c'est très très
long avec un principe de machine où on a
un magasin des matrices et on va fouler
les lettres en plomb sur place pour
fabriquer les lignes de caractère et
l'article de journal et donc ça ensuite
ça c'est envoyé sur le marbre pour faire
la mise en page
là c'est pas mal c'est pas mal du tout
les machines sont anciennes donc
capricieuses parce qu'il y a des il y a
de l'usure il y a des axes qui
commencent à avoir du jeu des choses
comme ça on a des sangles en tissus pour
pouvoir faire avancer le journal dans la
machine pour la plieuse tout ça ça va
être sensible à l'humidité à la chaleur
à l'hygrométrie et puis le moindre petit
réglage qui change va faire que ça
fonctionne pas alors pour entretenir les
machines aujourd'hui quand on a une
panne on peut pas trouver de pièces
détachées donc on est obligé de faire
appel à des artisans locaux où on va
amener la pièce défectueuse ou la pièce
qui a été cassée pour qu'il puisse nous
la refabriquer à l'identique il y a un
gros travail d'entretien la rotative
duplex date de 1924 les linotypes datent
des années 70 pour principalement celle
qu'on utilise principalement c'est
toujours un travail fastidieux de faire
fabriquer les pièces de démonter et de
régler les machines parce qu'il y a plus
de notice
donc on a à peu près 2900 abonnés mais
c'est principalement les abonnés qui
nous soutiennent et qui nous font qui
nous font vivre en plus des annonces
légales alors économiquement la presse
on a des difficultés comme tout le monde
dans le sens où en plus notre mode de
fabrication fait qu'on a un process qui
coûte beaucoup de temps donc beaucoup
d'argent donc l'équilibre il est
précaire on se bosse justement pour
pouvoir préserver le journal on est en
train d'améliorer les choses mais on a
besoin de Mécène pour nous aider à
sauvegarder ce patrimoine tout ce qui
est casse parisienne donc là tout ça ça
a été classé donc la case parisienne
c'est ce qu'on appelle la typographie
c'est quand on fait du lait à la lettre
donc tous les titres en gros caractères
sont fait antipographies on va venir
sélectionner ces lettres pour composer
la ligne de caractère là c'est l'être à
l'aide on a chaque chaque lettre et
rajouter côte à côte on voit bien que
c'est séparé donc il faut savoir que une
fois qu'on a fait ça qu'on a imprimé il
faut reprendre les lettres et les
oranger à leur place
donc là on vient d'être classé monument
historique aussi bien au niveau du
bâtiment que des machines c'est une
reconnaissance l'objectif de faire
classer c'est que étant donné qu'on est
une association de loi 1901 avec notre
équilibre financier est précaire demain
si on a une grosse difficulté les
machines peuvent partir à la casse
maintenant le bien est protégé par
l'État c'est à dire que l'État s'en
tient garantes donc ça c'est une
première victoire pour nous maintenant
l'intérêt c'est de le faire vivre
on a du matériel aussi qui nous est
donné par exemple l'année dernière je
suis allé à Orthez une imprimerie qui
est fermée donc on a récupéré la ligne
nautique qu'on a installé dans la ici et
qui va qui va refonctionner bientôt on
est en train de la réinstaller de la
brancher c'est une histoire de
transmission c'est à dire que l'immeuble
était vendu il restait une machine au
milieu de l'imprimerie il fallait la
sortir en cassant des murs et avec un
peu des fous comme nous démocrate pour
faire 6 700 km elle est casser des murs
pour sortir une machine d'une tonne 5
qui aurait été découpée cassée à la
masse et puis partir en ferraille